wherever
yes
um
is
first date
is
well
okay
uh
who knows
yes
[Music]
oh
oh yeah
oh
wow
yeah yeah
uh
thank you
here
okay
uh
you have these skills
foreign
huh
okay
sorry
right
me too
uh
good morning or good afternoon okay
a couple of items for all of you at the
top uh today
uh the biden harris administration has
launched child tax credit awareness day
to educate the public
and encourage non-filers to sign up for
the largest child
tax credit in history the american
rescue plan
increased the child tax credit to three
thousand dollars for families whose
children are between six and seventeen
years old
and thirty six hundred dollars for
families with children under six years
old
and allows half of that tax credit to be
paid to families in advance through a
monthly check
or direct deposit so starting on july
15th
almost all families who have filed taxes
in the last two years
will receive this monthly payment
automatically this means most families
with two young children would receive a
monthly payment
of 600 starting in july but we want to
make sure that everybody who's eligible
signs up
hence we've launched a website child tax
credit dot gov very easy to remember
and if anybody is not sure maybe they
haven't filed taxes
uh because they they don't they're not
required to they can go there and learn
if they're eligible
for this incredible benefit
second today the united states in
coordination with our allies and
partners in canada the european union
and the united kingdom
has taken a number of actions to impose
costs on the lukashenko regime in
belarus
for a variety of egregious acts last
month we said we would develop
a list of targeted actions against key
members of the lukashenko regime
associated with ongoing abuses of human
rights and corruption
the falsification of the 2020 election
and the forced diversion
of the ryanair flight today we are
following through and holding the regime
accountable
so earlier today the department of state
and the department of treasury
designated 62 belarusian individuals and
five entities
in response to continuing repression in
belarus
and importantly we did this alongside
our partners and allies
and with these coordinated actions on
both sides of the atlantic we are
demonstrating our deep and shared
concern regarding the lukashenko
regime's activities
uh finally today the biden harris
administration announced the
distribution list for the remaining
55 million of the 80 million doses of
america's own
vaccine supply president biden has
pledged to send out
globally and allocate by the end of june
in service of ending the pandemic
already we have sent millions of doses
to the world
including 2.5 million doses that arrived
in taiwan this weekend
and in addition sharing doses from in
addition to sharing doses from our
vaccines owns that
vaccine supply the biden-harris
administration is committed to working
with u.s manufacturers
to produce more vaccine doses to share
with the world and we've purchased as we
announced last week
half of the week before that half a
billion pfizer doses to donate to 92
low and middle income countries and
members of the african union
in total the g7 agreed to provide an
additional
more than one billion doses starting in
the summer of 2020.
that alex why don't you kick us off
right i have a few of the first
is on that vaccine allocation the
president promised to just redistribute
those
80 million by the end of the month but
he's obviously falling short of that
goal
so is there any indication that the red
taping this distribution is costing
lives at this point why is it taking so
long
well first let me say we've uh we're
committed to alec we've kind of it's
allocating those doses we've done
exactly that uh what we found to be the
biggest challenge is not actually the
supply
we have plenty of doses to share with
the world but this is a herculean
logistical challenge
and uh we've seen that as we've begun to
implement so
uh you know as we work with countries we
need to ensure that there's
safety and regulatory information is
shared some supply teams need needles
syringes and alcohol pads
transportation needs teams need to
ensure that there are proper temperature
storage
prevent breakage and ensure the vaccine
immediately clears
customs so this has not as you all know
been done before
sometimes it's even language barriers
that occur as we're working to get these
doses out to country so
we have announced today where these
doses are going we will continue to
announce
uh as they land on the ground and as
they are being shipped and we're looking
forward to doing that as quickly as
possible
and on infrastructure the latest
compromise we said earlier today the
president needs to see more details
um what details does he need to see was
he not able to take a look at the
package this weekend
um and one of the issues you've
obviously raised are paid for
so gas tax aside that being on starter
what
would the white house be open to um
specifically
some have raised potentially using
leftover
pairs fundings or funds from the
december
copit package would those be feasible
and
do you want to see the package
ultimately fully paid for
well first let me say that you know the
president's pledge
was not to raise taxes on americans
making less than 400 000
a year and the proposed gas
tax or vehicle mileage tasks would do
exactly
that so that is a non-starter for him
i'd also note
for the mathematicians in the room that
only raises 40 billion dollars
which is a fraction of what this
proposal would cost
the president has proposed a range of
ways to pay for this package
including ways that would not uh violate
the red lines the republicans have put
forward
one of them is ensuring the highest
wealthiest individuals in this country
pay what they're supposed to pay as it
relates to taxes additional tax
enforcement which would raise
a great deal more by multiples of what
the gas tax would raise
and it would uh it would fall on for
predominantly wealthy americans
and just ensure they're paying the taxes
they owe so that is an area where we
feel uh there should be an opportunity
to move forward
and as it relates to details of course
there needs to be ongoing discussion
there will be over the coming days
rapidly i expect to have
conversations this afternoon tomorrow
we'll read those out as those happen
provide information to all of you uh and
we're eager to get those continued
is the white house open to using those
electoral funds
to fund the development though well
one there's minimal very small amounts
that would be left over and
many of those small amounts have already
been allocated or
they are to help small businesses help
keep cops and firefighters on the beat
and so we feel the best proposal that
does not violate the red lines that the
republicans have put forward would be
uh tax enforcement and some other
proposals the president's already put on
the table
lastly on voting rights obviously
there's going to be a show vote on
s1 tomorrow that's going to fail so i
wanted to come back to president biden
pledging to do
whatever he could said he'd use every uh
sort of tool at his disposal to get the
bill passed what has he done to get that
bill passed considering this vote is
going to fail
and since he has pledged that is it time
for him to start
calling again for filibuster reform more
loudly that's a tool in his disposal he
has not yet
really pushed for well first let me just
give you a sense of how we see this and
how the president sees it
it's a step forward uh we don't expect
there to be a magical 10 votes i'm not
suggesting that but
just two weeks ago there were questions
about whether democrats
uh would be aligned we certainly hope
that will be the case tomorrow
it's important to remember that this has
been a 60-year battle
to make voting more accessible more
available to americans across
the country and our effort the
president's effort
to continue that fight doesn't stop
tomorrow
at all this will be a fight of his
presidency uh in terms of the steps he's
taken he's had conversations obviously
with members about
supporting this legislation including
senator manchin
as you all know over the last couple of
weeks
and he will continue to advocate he's
also asked as vice president or
agreed with his vice president that she
will be in charge of this effort moving
forward
it doesn't stop this is an important
piece of it the federal legislation
more work to be done but it doesn't stop
with that there's work to do in the
states there's work to do with voting
groups there's work to do
uh to empower and engage legislators and
uh that's something that will also be
part of her
effort and as it relates to the
filibuster uh you know
i don't think you have to take it from
us that would be congress moving forward
or making a decision
uh if the vote is unsuccessful tomorrow
it will i
we suspect it will prompt a new
conversation about the path forward and
we'll see where that goes
go ahead uh following up on
infrastructure you know senator portman
said over the weekend that he thought
that dropping the gas tax and this fee
on electric
vehicles uh could be something that they
could do so long as
the president puts forward ideas that do
not include raising any taxes
is that a potential compromise that
seems feasible
well again last i checked the proposal
the president put forward in his initial
proposal that has been a part of this
discussion
to increase investment in tax
enforcement ensure that people
who are the wealthiest are paying what
they should be paying in taxes which
would raise a significantly larger num
amount than the gas tax it does exactly
that and should meet his bar
and to ask the point do you want this
bill be fully paid for
the president has proposed means of
fully paying for
this package including the tax
enforcement components uh
he thinks that's a responsible thing to
do and we'll continue to have
discussions with
members about how we can find a path
forward you mentioned continuing
discussion should we expect another
in-person meeting perhaps here at the
white house this week
i suspect you can expect that yes
go ahead just going into this week how
does the president view
his role in these negotiations is he the
closer is he the facilitator like what's
his approach this week to try and get
this across the finish line i feel like
there's a baseball analogy here i won't
really want to deliver on
so my husband thinks i'm cool but i
can't think of it uh look i think the
president
uh having served 36 years in the senate
he's uh
always going to be deeply involved he's
always going to roll up his sleeves and
want to know every detail of what's
being discussed every detail of the
proposal and package
as i as i noted in response to mary's
question i suspect he'll have
some members here over the past over the
next couple of days to have those
discussions in person so
uh i don't know uh how you i will leave
it to all of you
to uh to characterize or give a label
for that but
uh he's ready to roll up his sleeves
ready the door to the oval office is
always open and
he'll be deeply involved and engaged in
this uh negotiations over the coming
days
some progressives have made the ask that
if you're going to move forward with
this bipartisan package
moderate senators commit to them to
supporting
the reconciliation piece of this as well
the second track if you will will the
president also seek
that commitment if they do move forward
on bipartisan peace legislation
well i would say that the president sees
this as a process that is
has multiple paths forward and the
reconciliation process which is already
underway
being led uh through the budget
committees in congress is an important
component of that
and a number of his priorities and his
proposals that he's put forward
are not a part of this negotiation or
not a part of this discussion
that's happening in a bipartisan manner
so he certainly would like to see
that move forward and he will make that
case to others as well just one last
question does he support the mansion
language on the voting rights issue
well uh you know again i think this is a
compromise
and as that happens as compromises
happen it means
there's a lot that you like about it and
it may not be everything you love
but he certainly sees this as a step
forward uh
and uh and as stacey abrams said over
the weekend
incremental steps forward in making
voting rights more accessible making
voting more
available is a good thing and he
certainly
is appreciative of the efforts by
senator manchin and others
to continue to make progress on voting
rights which he feels is a huge priority
go ahead
some quick follow-ups on things that
have already been discussed on
infrastructure the
meeting that would be taking place at
the white house this week do we have a
day
or uh people who would be attending on
that yet it's an excellent question
uh we will provide more details to you
as soon as we have them but
i suspect it could be more than one
engagement on voting rights um
there's been a lot of concerns expressed
about um
whether it's the mansion proposal the
the
two bills that have been already
floating in congress
that they actually don't address the uh
the key issues that are being faced
right now which is
local election officials being removed
being
taken their power being taken away from
them uh is the white house gonna say
anything about what
more needs to be done to deal with those
specific issues that are
happening right now yeah i think that's
an important point to raise um you know
even if the
uh voting rights bill was sailing across
the finish line with
support of every member of congress
there would still be more to be done
and that's why the vice president is
going to be leading this effort you're
right that some of that
is uh protections for officials and
states some of that is frankly pushing
back on the more
more than 40 states where there's
legislation moving forward that makes it
more difficult for people to
exercise a fundamental road right which
is the right to vote
so again this is uh not
the end of our effort this is in some
ways the beginning
um and there is going to be more work
done
by the president by the vice president
by the administration to expand access
to voting rights
just on the financial regulation
meetings happening in the oval office
today
there were a number of issues that i
didn't see on kind of your readout of
what was going to be discussed
um at that meeting you know it could be
anything from
the federal reserve signaling interest
rate hikes um
to the role that meme stocks are playing
in
um financial stability just anything i
mean
are those are those issues going to be
raised and and what more is going to be
just focused on well we'll provide a
readout of the meeting when the meeting
concludes i would note that
it is a routine meeting and most
presidents meet with their financial
regulators
there is of course um a couple of items
on the proactive agenda and when it's
concluded we'll provide a readout
including the state of the country's
financial institutions
uh work that they're all doing to
promote financial stability
uh implementation updates around climate
related financial risk
agency actions on financial inclusion
and access to credit
that's the proactive agenda as you know
in these meetings
different topics come up but this is
again in our view
a standard and routine meeting where
they'll discuss
the focus will really be on those topics
are you expecting any decisions to come
out of it
i think it's more of an update than it
is a decision
uh go ahead please jen uh back on
infrastructure
aside from the gas tax now the president
has had a chance to take a look at the
bipartisan plan
what does he think of it well i'd first
say that the president is encouraged
that democrats and republicans are
continuing to discuss a path forward on
rebuilding our roads our railways and
our bridges that's a positive sign
and this offer is nearly double what the
republican offer was
just a few weeks ago that's another
positive sign in the right direction
uh he's somebody who cares about the
details wants to have a discussion
and now that he's back in the united
states
and i expect he'll do that over the
coming days also
stay closely in touch with democratic
leadership about the path forward
but certainly he's encouraged by the
fact that the number has increased the
investments have increased
has some questions about the pay fors
which i've noted
and has a red line about the gas tax and
raising taxes on individuals making less
than four hundred thousand dollars a
year
is a one trillion dollar plan big enough
for him well i don't think we see this
as a
as a one step uh there is a
reconciliation process that's ongoing
and that addresses and includes a number
of the president's
key priorities including uh making uh
pre-k
universal for kids across the country
which would increase the likelihood of
graduating by more than 50 percent
making community college more accessible
there's a lot of investments and
proposals the president
has put forward because he thinks
they're important for our economy for
the american workforce for our
competitiveness
and a lot of those will be included in a
budget process that's already moving
forward
so even if this plan doesn't end up
being as big as he would like it to be
he believes there are other ways
to to get those policies enacted there
are a lot of vehicles to move his bold
ideas forward
um on medicare does the president
support bernie sanders proposal to
include
dental and vision in medicare it's a
great question i actually haven't talked
to him about this so i don't want to
speak out of turn let me do that and we
can get you all unanswered
finally um can you describe what
safeguards the administration has in
place to make sure that the children of
top officials don't get preferential
treatment and hiring
sure uh well let me say first that we
have
the highest ethical standards of any
administration in history
number of ethics officials have conveyed
that
and we're proud of that we have also uh
staffed up at an unprecedented pace
and that and this is the most diverse
administration in
american history so we certainly expect
that everyone
will abide by those high ethics
standards that applies in how we operate
it also applies and how
hiring is done go ahead
with the president back from his trip
with the kind of progress you've talked
about that he sees on infrastructure
is he seeing this as an inflection point
in terms of
urgency is his mindset at all different
uh after being rather patient in his
approach
without reach uh how would you describe
where his head is right now
uh concerning how quickly something can
get done because there are a lot of
people who are feeling like it's taking
too long
and that perhaps he has to have a more
active central public role
well i'd first say that um having lived
through a lot of legislative battles
himself he knows that sometimes they
take some time the sausage making takes
some time
but to your point um he does not feel
the time is unlimited
and he would like it is not weeks in his
view in terms of moving forward and
seeing if there's a bipartisan
path forward so that is why he's eager
to have these meetings and discussions
over the coming uh days um in uh the
white house and
see what it looks like see if he we can
address some of the questions he has
about this this proposal um and
certainly he'd like to move forward
sooner rather than later and on iran the
newly elected president has indicated
that he does not wish to meet with
president biden or to engage
on the components of the jcpoa
what is the president's view on that
well we don't currently have diplomatic
relations
with iran or any plans to meet uh with
the elite at the leader level
uh so it's unclear that anything has
actually changed on that front
i will say that the president's view and
our view is that
the decision maker here is the supreme
leader uh that was the case before the
election
is the case today will be the case
probably moving forward
uh the iran nuclear negotiating teams
just finished their six rounds of talks
uh they have not yet and yet announced
the seventh round but as is typical
they're back
uh consulting with capitals and uh we're
looking forward to seeing where that
goes moving forward go ahead peter thank
you jen on cover 19 origins jake
sullivan said this week
that if china does not let investigators
probing the cobot origins and they're
going to face
isolation in the international community
so what is an example of something that
the white house thinks china would care
about being isolated
from well i would say that as you know
from covering the trip last week there
was a great deal of calibration
around in the global community among the
world's largest democracies the world's
most important security partners
about how we were going to work together
to address
the rising economic power of china and
concerns where we have concerns which
the lack of transparency is certainly
one of them so
i think what the president and what jake
sullivan were referring to
is uh the global community has taken
notice we're going to work together to
exercise the necessary pressure on china
to be a participant and to provide
transparent data and access in this case
and
china wants to have a role in the global
community and global conversations and
and certainly they would take note of
that
so the white house's position would be
that isolation from the international
community is more of a
deterrent than say sanctions and
threatening sanctions or some other
form of punishment i think the point
that jake was making is that
china wants to be seen as a power in the
world as a central actor in the world
and
uh they they are not looking to have the
global community align against them
and then uh on infrastructure bernie
sanders is
pitching a reconciliation package that's
up to six billion dollars that includes
some of the president's other
priorities trillions i'm sorry six
trillion dollars it's a lot
more money that way
i'm just here to get you the accurate
info thank you very much if
something six trillion dollars big makes
it to the president's desk
would he sign it or is that too big well
first we're not quite there yet uh and i
would also note that the president has
put forward a
way of paying for these proposals
including what he feels are necessary
reforms to our corporate tax system uh
and asking the individuals the highest
income individuals the top one percent
to pay more and he's put a range of
ideas out there on the table and
proposals out there on the table we're
going to have discussions with congress
about
what it looks like what democrats are
comfortable with as well there's a range
of views in the democratic party as well
but we're not quite there yet and the
last one a dozen or so states have now
ended the federal unemployment benefits
the extra unemployment benefits a couple
more states are going to do that
in coming days does the white house
think that the governors who are ending
these
extra enhanced unemployment benefits
before they expire
are doing the right thing or the wrong
thing well
we have continued to implement or are
continuing to advocate to implement
uh these unemployment benefits for the
remainder of their
tenure which is just a couple of months
we we don't actually know because the
data doesn't exist yet what the impact
of the implementation in these states
is our view is that american families
there are still millions of people out
of work
they still need a little bit of extra
assistance we also don't think that
these benefits should be never ending
hence they're going to expire in early
september
so we know governors are going to make
their decisions we continue to believe
that
with more than 7 million people out of
work that there's still additional
assistance we should give to the
american public
why don't you go ahead after you said
afghanistan thank you very much
my name is journalist
as you know president ghanian doctor of
the law will travel
on friday to the white house washington
and visit with
president biden what will be the main
topic
that president biden will discuss with
both of them
and also taliban continues their attack
in afghanistan even today
uh white house has any plan to invite
taliban to
to convince them to make a ceasefire in
afghanistan because i've got people
there they
i have done that emotionally
we are in the bad situation understood
well i know that
um president ghani will be here in the
united states on pre-planned travel to
new york i believe and of course the
president looks forward to welcoming him
to the white house for a meeting on
friday
and i expect their topic their focus of
their conversation will
to be to continue to discuss how we can
work together to ensure
that afghanistan never again becomes a
safe haven for terrorist groups who pose
a threat to
the us homeland how we can work together
to continue to implement
uh the humanitarian assistance other
assistance
that the united states remains committed
to even as we work to draw down
our troops uh go ahead thank you jen
just two questions one in the wake of
the
supreme court ruling on the ncaa
uh college athlete compensation does the
white house believe that there should be
federal federal rules or some kind of
federal standard governing college
athlete compensation or is that a
decision
that the administration believes should
be left up to states
it's i let me just first say on the
ruling that
our view is that of course uh ncaa
student athletes
uh work very hard both on the athletic
field and in the classroom
i'm a retired one myself and today's
decision recognizes that as with all
americans their hard work should not be
exploited and the president believes
that everyone who works should be
compensated fairly for his
or her labor in terms of specific
regulations it's an excellent question
this is obviously a new
ruling i'd have to talk to our policy
teams about that and where we might
stand
i just won on coven 19. based on the
current projections
it does not look like the president's
july 4th target of getting
70 of the population at least
one dose of the vaccine will be met of
course the administration has
tried to incentivize vaccinations along
with corporations and other partners
what else can the white house do at this
stage to try and change the trajectory
of
vaccination rates and what are the
concerns of
missing that target in terms of the
president's desire to get back to
normalcy
well first let me say we've made
tremendous progress in our vaccination
efforts to date
and the ultimate goal has been to get
america back to normal as you said
and we're looking forward to doing that
even here at the
white house as you know we're we've
invited a thousand over a thousand
essential workers and military families
to join
uh the president on the south lawn and
many more uh with fireworks on
the mall uh what we've seen over the
course of the
past couple months in terms of progress
is a massive reduction in the number of
coveted cases by about 90 percent
a 95 reduction in the number of deaths
that are down that's significant
progress
we set this bold ambitious goal because
we wanted to continue to make progress
and we're doing exactly that we've seen
16 states meet it
what we what we've seen as we've dug
into the data is that
there is a big gap between individuals
25 and over
and 18 to 25 8 yes 18 to under 25
that means that's an area we need to
continue to work on
now regardless even if we sailed past
even if we do sail past the 70
goal we're still going to be vaccinating
people on july 5th
on july 7th on july 10th that is still
going to be continue to be part of our
objective
but as we dig into the data we know that
what we're seeing is a lower rate among
young people
that's concerning especially with the
delta variant being
on the rise as it as it is which does
not discriminate by age which still
could cause
death serious illness i expect in the
coming
days you'll get an update from our cova
team on where we are on the data and the
different categories as they dig into it
so i don't want to get ahead of them but
we're going to continue to run through
the tape uh we're also going to continue
to be
uh focused on where we can raise the
rates and raise the numbers where we see
uh there there are there's a lower
uptick of vaccination
go ahead thanks i think there's
oh thank you guys at least it's not a
cicada i swear
those things are okay but i i do have
actual questions
i appreciate it i was like is there
breaking news
but it's just yeah there you go okay so
i mean talking about the voting rights
vote there's supposed to be a test vote
tomorrow that is expected to fail
when you look at right now the the
prospect
for voting rights it's not very
high to get something through congress
as things stand
right now so what i would like to know
is if you can say specifically
what the white house plans to do if
you cannot get something some type of
federal action i know you said that
there are a lot of other things you look
at this as the beginning
of the process but ultimately on an
issue as fundamental as voting rights if
you cannot get federal action
what is left for the white house to do
well i don't think we accept that all
i'm the point i'm making is that it's
also state action it's also frankly
action that's been happening from the
department of justice
including increased funding and
increased implementation across the
country which is something that
the president and the attorney general
have both emphasized is a priority and
we've made some
specific announcements about so look i
think as we look to tomorrow
what's clear and what where we uh
what we're measuring i think is uh is
the democratic party
united we weren't as of a couple weeks
ago that's a step forward
um if uh if and when and as i will
acknowledge we don't
expect there to be a magical 10 or more
republican votes they've been clear
uh the republican party and republicans
in the senate they do not want to make
it easier to vote they do not want to
make it
more accessible for americans to vote
well where do we go from there
that is a conversation we're going to
have to have with leaders in congress
with democrats
uh with a range of members who also want
to see
advance advances on voting rights and i
expect the president will engage with
senator schumer and others on the path
forward in conversations
that means a conversation on the
filibuster i would think because like
you said there's not the 10 votes
in the senate and that being the case
what do you expect that conversation to
look like
are you having conversations with
senator manchin and others
about possibly making changes to the
filibuster at least when it comes to
voting rights
if anything is going to get done in
congress well
first i would say the president has uh
has spoken to his support for a talking
filibuster in the past
and at times other members have as well
it requires a majority of it requires
50 democrats to support changes in the
filibuster rules i will allow you
all to do your vote counting of where
things stand there i suspect
it's not just one or two individuals who
are opposed to that
i will note though uh as i said earlier
that
if the vote is unsuccessful i suspect we
suspect that may change the conversation
on the hill
we will see but i'm not going to get
ahead of where things are there's going
to be a vote tomorrow
uh democrats we suspect and hope will be
united in making voting
more accessible for people across the
country making sure we're advocating for
it as a fundamental right
this is an opportunity for republicans
to stand up and do the same
shouldn't be a partisan issue go ahead
oh thank you jen um
two topics for you um the first i wanted
to ask you about crime
is i want to understand is there a
concern at the white house
that there could be an increase in crime
this summer with it with pandemic
lifting and is that concern the reason
that the president is going to weigh in
this week no the reason is that there's
been actually a rising crime over the
last
five years but really the last 18 months
uh and so
it's an opportunity for the president to
speak to he's going to do to help
address that and as we've seen around
the country it is
a concern of many americans republicans
but also democrats too not necessarily
through a partisan lens
it was something that president felt it
was appropriate to speak to and tell the
american people what he's doing to help
address
would he be approaching this a little
differently than he did perhaps in 94
when there's another
prime wave that democrats responded to
can you talk to how his approach might
change
well i'm not going to get ahead of his
comments or remarks
later this week but it is an area where
the president feels a lot
a great deal of the crime we're seeing
as a result of gun violence
you can expect he'll speak to that and
his commitment to continuing to address
gun violence and gun safety in the
country uh
and certainly a long time has passed
since the
crime bill in 94 he's spoken himself to
uh
differences things he would stand by
things he would might do differently
but i wouldn't see this as a response to
that as much as a
uh conveying to the american people what
he's going to do now uh to help address
uh the rising crime we've seen over the
last year and a half i just wanted to
follow up on phil's question from
earlier about the um
mansion compromise that had been floated
just if you could talk specifically
about
his um idea or
if you could speak specifically to the
administration's position
on allowing or requiring some form of
voting id
when people go to the polls i think the
president's looking
i'm not going to go through different
individual pieces of the package it's a
compromise
the president there are components of
there of course that
i think universally among most democrats
in the country an extension of early
voting
uh making election day a law we would
support um this is a
a step forward uh should be seen as an
incremental step forward uh we'll see
what's the next step in congress go
ahead
thank you um a quick one on immigration
and then another topic
uh there's been reports atios is
reporting that the white house is eyeing
the end of july um for potential
timeline to lift
title 42 at the border cdc is also
referring to white house on this
does the white house see that as a
realistic timeline for potentially
lifting title 42
would we be at a place where vaccines
are continuing to be distributed and it
would be safe enough to lift that policy
well i don't have any new policy to
announce when it comes to title 42
there's been no change
we're not of course going to get ahead
of the cdc decision the process involved
in that which you just touched on a lot
of those components but
um we would let them pursue that process
would the white house prefer to allow
the outcome of that policy being
dictated by the current litigation that
the aclu was pursuing
or would that the administration
unilaterally make a decision
there's a policy process that's ongoing
that's unrelated to the litigation
in terms of the president's trip later
on this week to north carolina
the white house administration said
early on that when it came to vaccine
hesitancy a big part of the strategy was
relying on
local physician physicians local
governments as well to kind of take that
on
uh you know there's the vice president
took a trip recently the first lady's
taking treatment of the president taking
a trip
does this mark kind of a shift in
strategy when it comes to combating
vaccine hesitancy and when it comes to
that specific demographic you describe
younger people yeah what really do you
do to convince those people to take
vaccines at that point well first i
would say no
where we've invested our funding uh is
in
local empowering local trusted voices
whether they're doctors or clergy or
civic leaders that continues to be the
case
at the same time of course the president
and the vice president of the united
states should be out there advocating
for
the impact the efficacy of the vaccine
and and the impact and as a part of our
month of
uh action here a month-long campaign
it's it's absolutely appropriate for
them to do that
in our view um as it relates to young
people
uh you know i think uh we'll use some of
the same tactics we've deployed uh with
a range of communities right which is
uh trusted voices which is uh ensuring
you know
if a college roommate or a college a
former
college classmate got the vaccine and
now can go out and feel safe
going out to restaurants and concerts
that's pretty effective
maybe even more so than the president of
the united states appearing in their
local newspaper
that will continue to be an area we
invest we've also continued to make it
as
accessible as humanly possible that's
something we can do from the federal
government
we've seen that as a barrier uh in the
past we've made progress we've seen that
as a barrier we'll continue to do that
as it relates to young people
we're also incentivizing yeah yeah
sorry um sorry about that um it's okay
two questions okay two two questions uh
the first on
uh governors and governors races uh
across the country
you've been you have a number of
governors and candidates for governor
who are
becoming more and more explicitly
anti-government
in in their rhetoric and rejecting the
legitimacy of either the president or
the federal government in general
in areas that are undoubtedly the
federal government's
province such as a texas gubernatorial
candidate saying he would close the
borders you have the guy in
idaho running for governor who has
actually taken up arms against federal
agents
is the administration concerned that
actual violent extremists and people
espousing secessionist rhetoric are
finding a home
in republican primaries and could
actually be elected to office and then i
have that second question
well i'm not going to label people
domestic violent extremists officially
from here
uh i think we have certainly seen
problematic
rhetoric followers of q anon and
conspiracy theories
who not just who don't just run but are
elected to office so there's already a
record of that
um we'll continue to speak out against
that but
we will our our strategy at this point
is continue to advocate for
uh how government can work for the
american people uh remind people
across the country that this president
is going to govern for all americans not
just
one from one wing of a party or the
other and that hopefully the
effectiveness of that
is something that can help us play a
constructive role
related follow-up president biden's
predecessor
is going to return to his campaign-style
rallies in ohio
this coming weekend has anyone from the
administration reached out to governor
dewine
or anyone in ohio's government about the
possibility of
violence resulting from his return to
the trail
and is there any concern
him going back out there and continuing
to insist that the election is
fraudulent
uh and that he actually won could result
in
people being hurt or killed obviously we
take um
the rhetoric of uh uh the
the other the the former guy as we like
to say uh quite seriously uh as everyone
should uh but
i don't have any uh readouts or or calls
with governor dewine
i will see if there's anything from our
homeland security team to read out go
ahead thank you
you mentioned that supply in fact the
vaccine announcement was the main
was not the constraints logistics yeah
on june 4th gail smith said that they
expected the balance of the 80 million
is 55 million to come from the
astrazeneca shots those are obviously
still
under review should we infer from your
comment that you now expect the 55
million to be from pfizer madonna or
johnson and johnson
we've always had a range of options as
we are contingency planners here and we
have plenty of supply
to deliver on the 80 million doses as
you noted or as you
alluded to my former my answer
previously our biggest challenge is
logistics is the
fact that there's not a playbook for
this and there are challenges as it
relates to getting these doses out to
every country
certainly obviously once the fda if the
fda if the fda
approves us sending these astrazeneca
doses overseas that would be a part of
it but until then it wouldn't be of
course
you have an estimate then on how many
doses will be sent this month of course
the president fighting's
pledge initially was that 80 million
would be sent this month and now they'll
be allocated instead of sending
i i don't have an update on that it's a
great question i i know the kova team is
doing a briefing tomorrow but i will see
if there's more we can get back to
today i know you will be a loyal
attendee
uh going uh for the meeting this
afternoon one of one subject i wonder if
it'll come up is cryptocurrency is that
something the president is seeking the
advice
the agenda is exactly what i outlined uh
earlier uh and we will provide a readout
once the meeting concludes about the
topics discussed
with jay powell does he have confidence
in the job
is doing does he have any particular
message for powell in particular
the president's view is this is a
routine meeting with financial
regulators to get an update on
uh management of the economy uh and uh
arranged and making credit accessible to
people across the country
go ahead and just want to drill down on
the why has a decision on a vehicle
mileage tax for electric vehicles
can you explain the white house's
position and why you'd be opposed to
essentially
wouldn't it level set because people
fill up their cars with gasoline pay
into the highway trust fund
with the 18.3 per gallon excise tax
people who drive electric vehicles drive
on the same roads they don't pay
that tax why not well first i would say
the president wants to grow the electric
vehicle industry wants more
people to buy electric vehicles wants to
make them accessible to people across
the country
that will help our climate help create
jobs in that industry as well
and his view is that there are plenty of
ways to pay for
these proposals plenty of ways that will
not leave the burden on any individuals
across the country making less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year that's
the choice and he feels we should
we should uh have the burden on the
wealthiest americans as opposed to
any other americans what's the long-term
structural impact then on the
highway trust fund if as you hope more
americans drive electric vehicles fewer
people fill up their cars with gasoline
how do you sustain that if fewer people
are paying that excise tax over time
i suspect secretary pete has thought
about this i'm happy to talk to him
about it um over the long term
but again the purpose of this proposal
is to
move to electric vehicles as an industry
where people are
driving electric vehicles making our
climate uh making our climate healthier
but also creating jobs in this industry
that he feels as an industry of the
future
go ahead thank you the president has
been criticized for giving putin
a list of 16 critical infrastructure
targets
that's considered uh off limits to cyber
attacks
how did that idea come about and um
why not tell putin that everything
inside of the united states is off
limits
well first i i don't think it required
the president providing a list
to for president putin or russia to
determine what is critical
infrastructure in the united states i
know that has been
part of the conspiracy response to his
proposal
uh the president was being clear uh
these are areas where uh
you know we will be watching uh and we
will reserve the option of consequences
that was the message he was sending uh
during that meeting that's why he put
forward those specific examples
why didn't um he give putin a list of
targets inside of russia that the united
states would target if
another cyber attack um does take place
in the united states
because we don't preview our punches
one last question go ahead okay one last
question sure
does the president believe that a 15
week old unborn baby is a human being
are you asking me if the president
supports a woman's right to choose he
does
go ahead another question actually on
the
summit last week with putin a state
department official
after the summit uh said that
the havana syndrome these anomalous
health incidents among u.s personnel
had come up it was referenced who
referenced it to who
i don't have any more specifics from
that meeting to read out for you
why would the topic come up that there
is no confidence in this building or
with
intelligence agencies as perpetrator i
just don't we have not
attributed as you know i don't have
anything more specifically on this topic
from the meeting
reaction why else reaction on the
supreme court decision
to fulton versus the city of
philadelphia white house have a reaction
on that yeah
i think we have issued a reaction to it
i don't have anything more to it go
ahead i think we got to move on go ahead
and
go ahead right there yep go ahead right
go ahead i want you to follow up
on the geneva okay sure what specific
step
steps the administration is taking now
to implement understandings preached by
president biden and president putin in
geneva
uh i'm especially interested as you
probably understand in
in the potential dialogue with cyber
sure
and the strategic strategic stability
should we expect
in-person interagency meetings on that
or
i'll be talking about you know something
online
any idea about that sure so first let me
say the president did
accomplish exactly what he wanted to
accomplish in geneva which is
identifying areas where the united
states and russia could work together in
our mutual interests
we launched these strategic stability
talks part of their discussion was the
fact that there will need to be a lot of
follow-up
on a level that is below the two leaders
uh so that
uh some of that could be at the
secretary of state some of that will be
before
underneath that and those discussions
will be uh happening
uh or beginning and in the weeks ahead
uh but uh that was the agreement between
them that there would be follow-up from
their teams i don't have any more
specific update i suspect you would get
them
those updates from the state department
and others go ahead
go ahead but actually this woman right
in front of you i was trying to point to
her and then
i'll go to you next go ahead oh no no no
no right behind you go ahead
oh right here in the did you have a
question right there in the polka dot
church
go ahead okay no sorry on the debt
ceiling there's gonna be a fight coming
up next month
and uh they've been known to be epic
showdowns on debt ceiling
yeah so one of the president stands on
raising the debt ceiling
and that they cannot no agreement can be
reached
will the treasury department take
extraordinary measures
the president believes that congress
will do what they've done three times
during the trump administration which is
to raise the debt ceiling
we know that that will be a central
focus and discussion probably even in
here
come the fall uh but he expects they
will do what they've done three times
over the last go ahead
thank you um the president said
repeatedly on the campaign trail that he
opposes defunding the police
he's addressing rising crime across the
country on wednesday he mentioned this
what is the president's message to some
mayors who are considering reducing
police budgets or
already have reduced police budgets well
i would say person the president's
implementation of the arp part of the
funding that goes to late local and
state authorities
is to ensure that there are police that
are kept on the beat
uh obviously state and local authorities
are going to determine how they spend
that money
but certainly um he included that
funding uh because he feels it's
important to communities across the
country
yeah so i was wondering if you could
tell us about the president's reaction
some senate republicans are delaying
confirmation of his opm nominee over
fears that have confirmed she would
incorporate
what they see as a detrimental critical
race theory into federal directives what
is the white house's response to that
delay
uh the president believes that uh this
is a qualified nominee one the senate
should move forward
expeditiously so that we can ensure we
have a full team
in place across the government to
continue to work with democrats
republicans in congress
go ahead thank you just to follow up on
iran
now an eu negotiator said today that
they cleared on certain technical issues
but they still have problems on the
political one
um and some sources in vienna sorry
indicating that they might reach a deal
by the middle of july
is this optimistic what's your
assessment of that can a deal be reached
considering the
uh election the election rather of the
hard-line president
well again i don't have a new deadline
set here as you know because you follow
this closely they just finished their
sixth round
it's natural that they would be
returning to capitals the negotiators to
consult with their capitals and leaders
in their capitals
that's happening now uh our view is that
there is a decision maker here who and
that has not changed
uh and it is the supreme leader uh so uh
we
are going to continue to work to move
these diplomatic negotiations forward
because it's in the interest of the
united states
and the interests of our national
security uh but i don't have a new
timeline to set for you
on but that he's been the decision maker
before the election after the election
and even after an inauguration go ahead
thank you announced sanctions
against belarus today which include
visa restrictions property assets
designation
but previous reports suggested there
would be
economical targets uh that the
assumptions would be tougher
why have you refrained from putting
economic sanctions
on belarus which would be more
significant
well we just announced a huge number of
sanctions
and in coordination with our european
partners to send a clear message that
the behavior
is unacceptable not just the diversion
of the ryanair flight
but oppression of oppression of
democracy
within the country and that's something
again we did in coordination with our
partners because we felt these would be
the most effective means of sending that
clear message go ahead
why hasn't the president nominated
anyone to leave the fda at this point
i know there's this is a a popular and
understandable question uh certainly
he's eager to have somebody who's
uh qualified and uh prepared to
play to uh take on the role and he's not
going to
expedite it until he's ready to make a
decision and make an announcement
uh go ahead go ahead thank you jen yeah
the us
catholic bishops is writing a document
to clarify
who should receive communion and this is
targeted at
politicians people who have a high
public profile
what's the president's reaction to this
uh well joe biden is a strong man of
faith
um and as he noted just a couple of days
ago it's personal
uh he goes to church as you know uh
nearly every weekend he even went when
we were on our overseas
trip but it's personal to him he doesn't
see it through a political prism and
we're not going to comment otherwise in
the inner workings of the catholic
church
by the bishops make the president
reconsider his public support
for policies uh that you know
increase access to abortion or allow
acts to abortion again that the
president's uh
faith is personal uh it's something that
has helped guide him through
uh some challenging moments in his life
and that's how many americans see their
faith as well not through a political
prism uh so i would suspect he will
continue to
attend church as he has for many many
years go ahead jonathan
contradictory go ahead i think we're
going to move on to the next question
because i've just answered that and it's
personal go ahead
thank you oh there's a gubernatorial
election in new jersey uh governor
murphy's running for election he
endorsed the president last time to
raise money for him
is the president going to help governor
murphy win re-election this fall
well certainly he'd be eager to see him
win uh re-election of course and be a
continue to be an important partner in
the state of new jersey as we work to
address
continue to address the pandemic get
people back to work
in terms of what a specific political
plans are um i will
uh i don't have anything to preview for
you at this point in time uh
go ahead dan one more question about
iran um
on ibrahimovic the new president-elect
he has said that he's accusing the us of
breaking promises saying quote
based on the nuclear deal you were
obligated to lift the sanctions and you
did not fulfill your commitment what
does the
president have to say about that and
then secondly he's under u.s sanctions
for the 1988 political prisoner
executions
so how do you deal with them well
first let me say that the new president
will of course be held accountable for
violations of human rights on his watch
going forward we strongly urge the
iranian government regardless of who's
in power to
uh release political prisoners improve
respect for human rights and fundamental
freedoms for all
iranians um you know again i would note
and let me just say on the sanctions
piece that
as we're in these discussions in the
middle of these discussions after the
sixth round
the precise nature and sequence of the
sanctions related steps the united
states would take
would need to take to achieve a mutual
return to compliance
with the jcpoa is a subject of the talks
and of the discussions and we certainly
uh understand as we've seen in past
rounds of these negotiations that
there will be a range of rhetoric to
address
political needs at home we understand
that but our focus remains on these
negotiations
uh that we look forward to continuing to
participate in
uh yeah go ahead thanks so much um
and so even if you manage to reach a
nuclear deal or
deal with iranians on nuclear deal
re-entry republicans in congress could
force the vote to block sanctions relief
of course some of the democrats are
still in office including majority
leader schumer voted against the
original deal
when it was negotiated so are you
confident you have the votes in congress
to relieve sanctions and re-enter the
nuclear deal
well there isn't even a deal yet right
so i understand why you're asking in
that question but it's a little bit
ahead of where we are may we have a deal
where we can have that discussion
the important case that we are going to
continue to make
is that iran is not a good actor in the
world on a range of issues whether it's
human rights or their engagement in the
region
that continues to be the case and would
be even after if we get to the point
where we have
a deal but what is in the interest of
the united states what's interesting in
interest of the united states is having
that return to visibility that return to
uh an understanding of what their
capabilities are how close they are to
acquiring a nuclear weapon we're not
quite there yet
uh when we get to a point if we get to
the point when there's a deal we're
happy to have the discussion about the
legislative vote count
go ahead i thought you didn't take my
attention
no go ahead thank you so much president
biden recently announced
that the u.s will provide uh crown of
action to north korea
do you know how many doses and what kind
of
vaccine are we going to provide to north
korea
uh well we announced that we would be
providing about a billion doses
to the global community and the 92
countries
working through kovacs for 75 percent of
it
who are the lowest in middle income uh
countries uh in the world
uh that's what we've announced but i
don't have any more details than that go
ahead in the back
okay we'll go to this last one since i
just called on him and then we'll we'll
wrap it up go ahead
representing an audience that is quite
different from this gentleman's i'd like
to repeat his question
um the u.s supreme court decision in the
city of philadelphia v
uh fulton uh you said that the white
house issued a reaction to that i
don't believe that is the case um what
was the person briefed on that decision
i i thought we had if not i will get
that to you and to this gentleman over
here
thanks everyone so much uh we'll do this
again tomorrow okay
you